Let's do another example with
phone numbers. Phone numbers are
a tricky thing because sometimes
people put dashes in them,
sometimes people put parenthesis
or spaces or neither or pluses.
There's all kinds of different
characters that could go into a
phone number when sometimes you
might just want to store it as a
raw actual number. Now, I'm
going to assume that these are
US numbers. Obviously this would
be a little bit more involved if
it's an international numbers,
but we'll keep it simple here.
I'm going to first create what's
called a phone handler, and
that's going to do the trapping
of the set and get methods.
Let's first start with set, and
the set will take in the
target, the name, and the value.
Then we will go down here and
create a phone number proxy.
We're going to start off with an
empty object because there's no
phone numbers in it to start,
and pass it to phone handler.
When I set it, I could just set
the target name = value. Let's
try that out. What we've done
here is we've set the phone
number. We've got a plus here.
We have a space that someone
accidentally put in. We've got a
dash here, sometimes there's
going to be parenthesis.
Let's set another one,
phoneNumber.work is maybe
something like two, three, four,
and they only put spaces in it
in that case. Now we have
phoneNumbers, which is an object,
with some not nicely formatted
data inside of it. What we
can then do is, when someone
sets it, we can clean it of all
these characters that are non-
numbers. We will say target.name =
value, and then we'll just run a
match against that, only for
numbers. Then we'll join it
together once we have it. Now,
I should be able to say
phoneNumbers.work, and then when
I pull up phoneNumbers.work is
just a actual number. Same goes
for the home one that we did.
When I pull up phoneNumber.home,
it will now be stripped of all
of your dashes and spaces and
any other characters that might
have then come on in with it.
We could go one further and
actually store it as number if
we wanted to, but let's do it on
the flip side of when I actually
pull it out of this object, we
want it to be consistently
formatted. That will be our get,
and from this we're going to
return the target name. That's
the default operation. What
we can do is use a .replace
RegExp here to format it in a
standard phone number fashion. I
just pulled this off the
Internet here, and now when we
try to set something. Let's try
work. Now when I pull the work
out, we intercept it with this
get trap and then we format it
as it comes out. No matter
how I pass in the values, it's
always going to pull it out and
format it very nicely for me.
That's another good example
where you might want to use a
handler. Again, we're using set
and get to step in between on
the proxy. One other thing
we did here is we didn't start
with an existing object, we just
passed it a blank object and
then use that to set values on.